This is going to be my final Direct Message
of 2017.
Last week we put up 5 shows in 5 days for
Rubin Report YouTube week, this week we've
got my sit down with former National Public
Radio CEO Ken Stern, and next week we'll be
highlighting some of my favorite episodes
of the year.
Today's Direct Message is going to be quick
and to the point.
With incredible gratitude and a humble heart
I want to thank all of you helped make 2017
such a memorable year here at The Rubin Report.
The ride to get here, from 12 years of stand
up comedy in NYC, to my pop culture radio
show at SiriusXM, to hosting on The Young
Turks to joining Larry King on OraTV and finally
to this independent show funded by you, has
been a long windy journey....one which I wouldn't
trade in for anything.
It's only been a year and a half since we
made the move to independence, and as some
of you have heard me say, the night before
we launched on Patreon, I literally thought
my career, as well as the careers of my team,
might be over.
Fortunately within hours of launching we quickly
realized that not only was it not over, but
we were just at the beginning.
In the 18 months since then, I bought a home
in which we built this totally professional
home studio, we expanded the team behind the
scenes, the show absolutely exploded with
almost 400,000 new subscribers and most importantly,
we've continued to have honest, civil conversation
that hopefully has left you feel a little
more enlightened and a lot less alone.
This year we did an on location shoot with
Ayaan Hirsi Ali.
I interviewed Richard Dawkins in front of
a live studio audience in New York City, we
helped put important voices fighting for academic
freedom on the map like Jordan Petersen, Bret
Weinstein and Lindsay Shephard.
We hosted a conversation on religion and morality
with Dennis Prager and Michael Shermer.
We introduced you to incredible voices fighting
for liberalism like Yamine Mohammed and Lubna
Ahmed.
We also introduced you to some previous guests
like Peter Boghossian, Eric Weinstein and
Gad Saad, all of whom are great guests, but
more importantly have become great friends
as well.
And of course, we also hosted the infamous
debate between Blaire White and Candace Owens,
which got me trending on Twitter for the first
time in my life, hashtag Save Dave.
Your support also allowed me to take some
time off in August to work on my book and
take 30 truly life changing days off the grid.
In an age when we never get off our devices,
when we're slammed with news about terrorism
right after we scroll past a cat video and
a picture of your high school friends new
baby, you guys gave me the greatest gift I
could ask for...a little time to reset and
rejuvenate.
And in exchange for you giving me some of
that precious time, we made sure to have all
new shows for you throughout August ready
to roll while we were gone.
I've got a long list of people to thank for
making everything happen here, but I have
to give personal shout outs to David, Amiria,
Alexis, Talia and Emma.
There's an incredible amount of work that
goes into producing these shows and the only
reason it looks easy is because of the team
that I have helping me make it look just that
way.
I also want to give a special shout-out to
those of you who provide us with monthly support
on Patreon and PayPay, or who have done one
time donations via Bitcoin.
Your support not only keeps us independent,
but has given me the luxury of saying no to
several big money offers this year.
As long as that support remains, I see no
reason to change that, and I promise I will
do my best to make sure to continue to earn
that very support.
And of course, thanks to all of you who watch,
share and like these videos.
We've never put a dollar into YouTube ads,
but the show continues to grow because you
help it do so.
The emails that I get from you saying how
you're putting the ideas we discuss here into
action, or changing what you believe because
of something you've heard, or just are talking
to people in a new way because of the tone
we've set here is incredibly inspiring.
And I'm sorry if I don't write everyone back.
Trust me I'm trying!
So thank you, thank you and thank you.
This time of year is when we give thanks and
show gratitude and it's all of you who have
given me so much to be thankful and grateful
for.
I look forward to kicking off 2018 with you
soon enough but in the mean time Merry Christmas,
Happy Hannukah, happy new year and May The
Force Be With You.